so
[Music]
hello
okay so the name of this game is thomas
the shank engine it really made me laugh
and i was like i don't even care if this
game is crap or bad or something maybe
it'll be scary i was like
i gotta play thomas the shank engine
looks like i fell asleep waiting for the
train
wait
where am i
i don't know
oh that's me
oh
what was that
do you guys see something
what is that i see in the tunnel down
there am i supposed to go in the tunnel
am i supposed to worry about my
oh
don't shank me please
okay
i don't think trey
what am i doing
what are you doing what are you doing
thomas
uh
okay
um oh radio
[Applause]
did you just tell me to die why
this lever are you gonna jump scare me
again
okay good that's what i thought
yeah i'mma go in also who are you also
why am i also where am i
oh
hi
oh
[Music]
what is happening
oh no
oh oh oh
[Music]
man that got here a lot sooner than i
thought it would
oh my god
oh my god
oh what
ha
[Applause]
which way did you just go
oh
which way you going okay that's fine
oh
where
oh
[Music]
all right
you ain't that scary
you ain't so bad
oh my god
so you got some blood on your drain
there
okay that's fine that's fine that's fine
we can deal with that we can deal with
that i don't know where i'm going and i
don't know why i'm going there
but uh which way which way which way
which one okay all right i see you i see
you i see you it's fine
that's fine
all right
something blue there there's something
blue please tell me that's not behind me
oh it's not buying me it's in front of
me
hi thomas
okay um yeah there's something blue over
there i don't know if that's where i'm
supposed to go
aha okay this is fine
i'm gonna follow him down
okay
i don't know what this is supposed to be
but there is blue here
uh
oh that's not good
what
okay okay okay
uh yeah i'm gonna go i'm gonna go i'm
gonna go i'm gonna go i'm gonna go okay
that's your code
i don't know the
code i don't know the code um was there
supposed to be a code somewhere around
here because i don't know the code all
right let's go see if we can find a code
oh
so i there's no reason to go down here
because i could die in an instant to
that
but i don't see no code nowhere
i ain't seeing no code
this is a little
deadly
[Music]
oh is that behind me
oh
man
okay which way we going tommy
all right so it is you can hear it
i don't know where the code is oh green
that's something that's something that's
something that's something what is this
whose security code
e674
okay handy that
8674 okay that's good that's good that's
good
okay 8674
oh
god
wait a minute wait a minute that was
that was really fast
oh my god nope not today
eight six seven four i remember
i remember okay
uh
eight
cool six
what
why would you put it in backwards
okay
eight six seven four seven
six eight
eight six seven four door opened what
door what door
what door what door got opened what door
do you mean
why is everything so dark
what happened
oh that's quick
i don't know what door i don't know what
door you mean i don't know what door
what door is you talking about
oh my god
oh my god okay i gotta be super vigilant
okay i'm in trouble i'm in trouble
oh my god
i'm in trouble i'm in big trouble um
i'm in
oh my god please no not today not today
frick
oh my freaking
i don't know where i'm going
i don't know where i'm going where am i
going
this door somewhere here
that opened but where
[Music]
oh god if it opens in front of me i'm
done
my god i have no idea where the door is
so i i
i should look for it first when things
are not oh no it's it's full on no it's
it's beginning it better be
hey
oh
easy there pal easy there pal
okay all right you're slow back down so
i gotta find this door first so that i'm
not running around hunting for it
as i'm being
plowed
okay here's where a code is
there's the door okay that's good
that must be the door all right
9843 but i gotta put that in backwards
nine eight four three got it okay i
think i saw the blue over here somewhere
okay there we go that's fine
nine eight four three
wasn't that it oh god i just lost it
what was it oh [ __ ]
what was it 9843. wasn't it 9843 i think
it was
9843
[Music]
9843 got it got it got it i think
[Music]
okay i gotta put in let's sew three
four
eight nine
door open okay done
easy peasy
[Music]
[Music]
okay here we go
here we go here we go oh god oh god oh
i survived i don't know how
okay
wasn't it down one and then over this
way to the left here i think yes it's
right there
[Music]
[Music]
oh i'm still going turns out my phobia
is uh getting hit by a train you know
what is that
oh
hi oh my god i'm done kill me
i
crave death
oh wow oh well this is the end for me i
guess
oh wow hi
uh
what can i do for you what can i do for
oh my god
well i can't move so whoa oh i'm dead i
didn't know that i was anything i could
do to it
atone for my sins what if i how is this
the scariest game i've played in a long
time how is this one
so i can't move
out of this area
i can't move back
that's all blocked off so what do you
want from me exactly
i don't i'm dead what
uh
i'm a little confused i can't move
forward
i'm trying it's not letting me
i can't go that way
i can't go this oh i can go this way oh
oh i can move now oh i can go forward
now okay um
i don't know if it's just a matter of
him coming and killing me oh wow that's
fast uh death is approaching i'm sure
oh my god
okay so just after a moment there i'm
just gonna run and i gotta get to the
other side that's that's that's what i
gotta do okay i understand now
okay i get to go now
okay i'ma save my sprint for when i'm
dodging it apparently
oh god
goodness gravy
wow how how do you
how would you i tried to strafe i guess
i gotta like run straight to the side
okay so as soon as i see it zoom past
the other way i'm gonna start running
directly to the side
so it goes down and then it goes
up and i'm going i'm going i hope i'm
putting my oh
i'm alive oh my god i'm alive oh my god
i'm not alive
i'm not going to be alive okay it's
coming around again then goes back up
what was that
what
what was it
what do you mean what do you mean what
do you oh okay
i didn't
i don't know how you move
um maybe it is just like a pattern
and he's not actually coming to me
i don't think so but i don't know so so
i don't really know
i might experiment with this because i'm
going to go over here
see what happens when i'm like here
it goes down and he goes that way
oh so it is just a pattern okay
so it's a pattern right okay he goes
down
oh god
i know he cuts across the front here
for a bit oh my god
well there's no way that i could ever
dodge these things he comes down the
middle
oh god i know he do
he comes down this middle right here
at some point
there he go
oh wow
great bod pal
um
oh my god go go oh my god please okay
[Music]
oh my god okay uh i go i guess i don't
know
what is this train whistle give it to me
how's that like the scariest game
how
i don't
no that was amazing a little tedious at
the end but that's okay all right
moving on
this is midnight visitor
why is there an elevator here
okay you play as a detective who just
solved a big case now with your boosted
ego
was this game know me or something you
have your eyes on an unsolved case a
woman died in this apartment and any
detective who decided to investigate the
craze never returned
you're here to solve this case and make
history with my big fat
ego
okay
[Music]
make way for my big ego
i don't think this door is big enough to
fit my ego
well
seen it a million times
corporeal ghosts rising from the body of
the recently deceased whoever drew this
chalk outline was terrible truly
terrible didn't even clean up the blood
was that about detective mode
[Music]
wow only big ego people like me can
detect this there are no footprints
leaving
ah there are no footprints leaving i
write things in my own special way the
english language isn't enough for me to
capture the magnanimity is that is my
ego
shot
can't find the murder weapon though
maybe it's hidden somewhere they always
leave the murder weapon in the murder
location
so says me
big egoman
i like this
that's actually kind of cool
that's normal
ow my eyes
my sweeping senses detect nothing in
this room
however in this room
i see their porno collection is
rather lackluster when compared to mine
what am i looking at
oh
found a security recording
now if only i had a place to play it
oh
what about this
elixir make time go faster
hmm
that seems to be recording in the living
room
how odd there's no body
useless
completely useless
look at crunch brunch
no no can't check with the neighbors
don't need to
got everything i need right here
in this room
oh i can open these
oh
there's something in there for some
reason i can't seem to grab it
oh eight o'clock this loser left his
front door open i'm gonna kill him as
soon as he returns
heard some footsteps outside looks like
he's back why is he trying to enter from
a window does he know i'm here
i gotta stay alert
wait is this a no from the murderer or
the murdery
did you leave this note mayhaps huh even
my big brain
detectiveness can't decipher this
mystery
sure wish i could see what i'm doing
aha
god i see nothing can the light stay on
for just a little bit could i get some
light please
what
wait
wait a minute what
that's me i think it's something about
the loading the dynamic loading is
causing that light to unload or
something like that that's weird
all right anyway
um
i
have
i have a flashlight
all right
now no mystery is too far from my grasp
i will see to it that this mystery is
solved
once and for all
better check the fridge for any
valuables
wouldn't have seen that
i found a key
i wonder where
my detective ego is telling me over here
how suspicious hi
who's in there
murderer
murderer
murderer
the recently deceased
i will find out what happened to you
whether you like it or not
hello who was murdered in here
or who murdered he's not here found
someone fooling around had to kill her
she'd blown my cover never believed in
ghost but now that she's back for
revenge i regret killing her tim loved
him
tiny box tim
what has become of you
oh
that's a hand
something tells me this is oh i see
there's a shadow on the wall ah well
this is very oh
i'm done 713.
well that's convenient
good thing my detective skills allowed
me to do that
seven
one
three
a
that's fine i'm so polite as a expert
detective i close the doors behind me
whenever i enter a new room
i'll be with you in a moment ma'am i
found some blood this clearly takes
higher priority
okay this could
okay well this is
someone either shat blood all over the
floor and then also the bathtub or uh
someone was murdered here
all right interesting
hi what is it
what is it
all right okay okay i get it quite a
beat someone's just practicing drums
over there i shouldn't bother them
i wonder if there's something aha
well that's a little weird ma'am
if you could stop crying i can't hear
this ludicrous beat slapping over on the
other side of this door
well my job here is done the woman isn't
murdered at all
turns out she's totally fine
i don't have anything to say about this
blood with my investigative abilities
my god
okay well i guess i'm stuck
did i break it
am i broken i see a hand there that's
the same painting as before i'm trying
desperately to detect things and yet i
see nothing
ma'am can you give me a clue as to what
i'm supposed to do here i can't even
jump or anything
i think i think that actually probably
is the sound of something being very
broken um let me try that again because
uh
well that didn't work all right let me
try it it shouldn't take me too long to
get back to where i was oh
excuse me ice detective coming through
what do we have here is this mystery
footprints i see good hey wait let me
take a look at this let me take a look
at this let me take a look at this
what's in here this top drawer right
here wham bam thank you and
i'm gonna look at you right there got it
nailed it perfect every time because i
am the best got the recording putting it
over here in the tape recorder not even
going to look at it
autumn away professional coming through
taking this got that moving here going
over there thank you no thank you have a
good day
hi
coming through
i see something i missed a gun that's
interesting found the murder weapon i'm
even better than i thought i would have
been
useless just like all of my former
partners who decided to die i know the
code 713 bama rooney let me double check
in here in case there's something i
forgot note received flashlight don't
need it drawers
impossible to open
maybe
maybe that's the thing maybe i wasn't
supposed to open it oh my god
what how does this
move
this is the worst okay whatever got it
nailed it perfect 713. coming through
got a murder weapon now maybe i'm gonna
need to use it
excuse me is this blood yes no
all right
who's there
bang
key
there was a key there
[Applause]
excellent i'm on my way hmm seems
interesting how is this is this the
simulation i was promised the case not
endless pt hallways i'm so smart and
egotistical that i am very meta about
what i do
hi
hello
who's over there
oh oh
oh oh i didn't do that
oh no
oh no
oh no thank you
i'm okay
[Music]
okay
oh
whoa whoa okay hey i got a gun you back
off there whoa hey whoa easy
easy lady
all right thank you
ah
missing oh
missing
oh hi
no
oh did you just kiss me all right well
that i think that's the end
cool good great i liked the detective
thing that was ambitious haven't seen
people try to put like an investigative
mechanic into these things not very
clear when i'm investigating and the
things that i need don't pop up but it's
okay i liked it it was good
moving on
this is tornukto
tornuk2 ah with christmas came some
christmas horror games and i didn't play
them for christmas but i'll play them
now
late one winter polar night you find
yourself unable to sleep awoken with a
strange uneasy feeling with your mother
fast asleep you decide to move to the
living room with not much to do you
start reading an old book you found at
the town bookstore earlier that day
all right
all right mom i'mma read a book
very snowy out there
marie the book now
the tornu is an evil creature
originating from alaskan folklore its
physical form is described as having
both human and reindeer characteristics
it has the head of a reindeer but with a
human teeth which wrap around its entire
face
gross it has the body of a man but with
the hooves for feet its skin is pale
white but is covered in black fur and it
has eyes that glow in the dark okay
it is said to be especially tall when on
his hind legs and capable of walking
like a human however it is also capable
of galloping like a deer and can travel
at high speeds in almost a floating
manner
well that was a great story can't wait
to go to bed hey
what a lovely night not an animal in
sight all right i'm tired i'mma go to
bed
well that's no place for me
hey ma
ma
all right
was that uh
was that all was i supposed to do
something else
hello
was i not done reading
should i have read more
[Music]
okay
oh the tornoque ii is said to only be
seen in the months of november through
january during these months alaska
experiences a time of darkness also
known as polar night where the sun
ceases to rise it is believed that
tornooktu is unable to attack outside of
these months due to a weakness
to the sun
once the polar night starts the tornuk2
is said to be starving and will begin
its hunt invading people's homes and
eating them it is believed that the
tornuchdo targets those who build their
homes far from others in secluded places
thus to be safe from an attack people
should live closely to one another
yeah no thanks
what a bunch of
hooey
hello oh i'm really in my
okay all right well
hey ma
did you hear there arose such a clatter
a little bit ago kind of sounded like
santy claus
you coming in the back door
i'm sure it was just the wind
i'll go ahead and close that
oh
oh yeah
the snowman i built okay
that's fine
i'm
[Music]
that's weird
that's pretty weird
you know i'm not gonna lie that's uh
that's weird
oh
what a creative snowman
oh
good
a sign tornutus near is finding snowmen
like figures which are said to have
faces of the dead and smell like human
corpses it is believed such figures will
surround a house before tornuk2 attacks
another sign it might be near's
excessive feelings of fear or distress
with no direct cause
well that's vague i don't know what it's
talking about
i don't feel fear at all
right mom
are you uh
you asking me to stick my head in there
are you asking me to stick my head in
there listen
i'm a very busy man i don't have time to
go sticking my head in random fireplaces
already did that checked it there's
nothing there
raleigh fine
hey mom
mom
all right ain't no [ __ ] ain't no
betraying no [ __ ]
i ain't no [ __ ]
okay
fine see told you told you i'm a brave
brave boy
ah reading time again
the tornutu also carries a bag made of
fur which it uses to steal children from
the house it attacks it is unknown where
the children go when they are taken some
say the tornutu eats their soul to
attain immortality
others that it keeps them to eat
throughout the rest of the year
well they say a lot of things and how
would they know they've never seen this
tornook too and besides i'm way too
large to fit in any sack
i'm a big boy i'm a big man
mom
[Music]
mom
well i better read more yeah now it was
time to read more
definitely read more now
it is believed the only way the
tornooktu can die is to starve to death
so once it finds a house to attack there
is nothing that could be done to stop it
well that's good to know
[Music]
um
oh
[Applause]
that is a concern
oh you and your creepy shot
that was well done
that was pretty good
that was downright creepifying
damn i'm impressed
like i gotta admit i'm impressed oh it's
the same guy that made slide in the
woods
good stuff
good stuff
very good
very good
[Music]
so
[Music]